yo hotel they sold for hip-hop real 92.3
already know what it is bootleg cat DJ
damage we got my brother in the building
right now it smells really good another
amazing we got natural and burner what's
up with y'all Melbourne how you been man
I'm good man enjoying the busyness LA
yes so like for everybody who don't know
burner is a Taylor Gang official artists
official tissue he also happens to be
like the I want to call you like the
Warren Buffett okay a little hip-hop
weed game this the weed game maybe
period yeah I got my own little agency
right now we're starting you know my
name is Jerry Maguire you know there
Cherry Blossom Road Oh Pat like you you
really help like even with kind of get
involved with a lot of the business side
of the cannabis industry right yeah man
a lot of people don't understand that
this [ __ ] is I'm sorry this business is
a lot more complicated we can edit it we
can dispense a lot more complicated than
people think it is people just want to
throw a name on a strain and put it on
the shelf it doesn't really work like
that like people put their heart and
souls into creating good weed and it
takes a lot of time energy and emotions
to get what you smoke on the shelf so
you know I just kind of tapped in a lot
of different ways I spend a lot of time
doing this and which is you know my
brother so put him discipline or you
know I somebody who formerly may or may
not have sold marijuana I feel like your
music is just like yo yo it's like like
obviously you were moving for us a weed
prior to it being this big legal thing
yeah yeah but talk about the transition
because obviously there had to been a
point where it went from like you know
worrying about PACs getting intercepted
going to the Midwest to you know lien
you know like being able to promote it
and get official money me personally the
transition is beautiful because I've
established a brand and credibility and
and in this business where it's like
legit the logo could get licensed now
and we could we can come in and check
out a facility and help curate their
menu and give them all the advice they
need to not mess up their their business
their operations so for me it's good you
know I just want to see illegal anyways
I don't want to get pulled over and be
looked at bad for having weed or smoking
weed I hate worrying about it when I go
to other places so identity the
transition for me has been cool because
of you know how much work I put no
you know we see you in the blogs the
vlogs that you make we see on stages
what some of those growing pains is
burner you know you get to this point
and the biggest growing pain is that
everybody still thinks I'm with the
business so it's like he running
something I what's up Brian honey I need
like a honey brownies like why was it
for various so I think that you know you
see the disappointment in some people's
eyes you know it's like they look like a
sad puppy but the hardest thing for me
really is just kind of like you know
just kind of getting out of that
lifestyle and being like paranoid from
that lifestyle like just I've been
around this for a long long time so you
know the hardest obstacle for me is
being taken I guess some people don't
really take the music series but I got
26 maybe 27 albums under my boat and
they all sound good from top to bottom
they all ride and so you know that's
that might have been a little hurt but I
think it's kind of its kind of
resonating with people right now do you
feel like um you because you know you
put out the you didn't put it but the
vice land put out the Bay Area thing and
a lot of the homies were featured in it
but I remember you kind of had a issue
with they came and shot a lot of [ __ ]
with you and they didn't use any yeah
you know my whole thing was I was at
home getting some head watching TV
relaxing like legit like the most
relaxed day ever and I get a call they
want to meet you and I'm like I know how
this thing goes they're going to meet me
and they're not it's just they're not
going to use it now now now they want
they want to holler at you will move so
I got out of my bed I left my
comfortable situation I mean like I said
all right topped off smoking big relaxed
and then I go meet up with them and I
spend some time with them in they don't
use it my whole thing is like look dude
I make legit every hour I'm making money
while I'm on the phone whether I'm
thinking whether I'm working so you took
money out my pocket
you took away my Sundays why yeah like
I'm chilling so I'm really tripping off
it like that but just I just get sick
when people waste my time look at the
time is valuable so you know you can't
get it back
is it like I guess to me I think it's a
little frustrating as its because I'm a
fan of your music I think you know I
think as an artist here if you're very
underrated I think you put quality music
out four or five times a year maybe is
crazy but is it a little frustrating
because I feel like the bay there's this
new wave like shout out to Dez
shout out to Kalani obviously the hpk
gangs been doing it for a very very long
time
but I don't feel like you get mentioned
when like people talk about the new Bay
Area Renaissance is it kind of like
frustrating to not be mentioned with the
cool kids or not you know the well again
it's like it's almost damn near on it
because I got my own lane and I've made
it this far like me shout to everybody
here right now because I ain't been in
1:06 cameo like I'm talking about I sell
out venues with 8700 people in my city
and I'm not on the radio right oh you
know at the end of the day like it's
frustrating but it's not because I'm
making a good amount of money right now
and my businesses are successful and I
can honestly say I did it from the
ground up with the hardest you know from
from the hardest grind ever like we're
not being played on radio not getting
support from like look you know a lot of
you know media and television I mean
really didn't work out and that's why
like you said I dropped four or five
albums here because I'm working three
times as hard as the average artist but
I like it because you know it's a
blessing and a curse at the end of the
day like the people that recognize me
have definitely done their due diligence
and it's like a little coat I feel like
Tyler Deardon almost look like well why
do you feel like you don't get that
recognition you know musically I mean I
hate to say it I'm not going to you know
I'm not going to be one of the spirits
of one that I'm Latin a lot of you know
it's hard for them um it's hard for them
to push they don't they can't really
offer one before you're not black enough
for this station you're not Latin enough
for this station well I'm a person I'm
not anything a person so that made no
sense but I think it's one of cuz I'm
Latin too just because of politics and I
don't really make music that caters to a
mainstream audience I make music you can
ride to get high to in vibe to and that
might not really be what they're looking
for but at the end of the day like you
know like in this room there's love and
there's people acknowledge the work that
I'm putting in and that the music is
timeless you know you can listen to one
of my albums probably ten years from now
I'm still going to sound good as
timeless it's not like catching a fad or
none like that's not like a it's not
like a certain time that ptui everyone's
trying to rap a certain way or rap over
certain beats like this going to be just
like a polo t-shirt you bust out this
polo sweater
ten years from now so relative life it's
still gonna work and so that's how I try
to make my music so you'll talk about
the independent grind because obviously
man like I remember you like putting out
like records like and Pacino and like
yeah like I mean then obviously we was
playing your record in Vegas the yoko
record which is which had a big create
Chris Brown wears on it and that has
2010
Levin that was like in 2009 or 10 maybe
yeah and yeah trigger my video I never
thinking like that and it's ooh but I
remember seeing your name like unlike
independent [ __ ] prior to that but like
that was like I think the first like
really big look or people like oh [ __ ]
who is this random that video do it like
that that videos got the best story ever
- I would that's Bay Area wiggle 101
like the way we got to race track and
the race cars and I mean people that
look like $150,000 video I probably
spent 11 grand on that video and it was
just mouthpiece but I went down there
and convinced to do to do it but the
independent the independent grind is the
best because you control when how where
and what you're going to drop so it's
like I mean Styles P to start a vibe
anomaly just shout out album in five
days create two videos the album cover
and you know a nice little blog and
we're dropping the end of June and me
and Dolph got one in the works to drop a
novelty project you will probable yeah
me install and it's on a whole other
ways and what me and styles album is and
it's a full album in styles I'm Mia Wiz
Khalifa got a full album dropping on
Christmas call from C to say Lou I'm
able just to work without without the
headache and when you're independent if
you do it right
like I'm clearing all the samples for
the wizard right now myself and getting
it done that's why you got some time yes
late you like legit like I'll tell you
on the web all these albums are done
they're all I need to do is just kind of
put it together a little bit so who else
would you like to collab with I see you
working with Dolph and of course Wiz
yeah he said Styles P escalated with cam
yeah I got a project with camera I want
to be real multiple times we have a
whole series well so who would you love
to work with EJ quit man get at me boy
come on man Branagh come on get some of
the quick beats man I just that's and I
want him to produce a whole project cuz
that's just like you know I grew up on
the sugar free and the quick hide you
see he could like match my style and put
me on some whole game that's who I've
been really that's on the bucket list
and we spoke about it once in person but
and I need to execute I feel like wick
has like the most underrated dis line
ever when he said II IHT but should I
continue maybe you left out the G
because the G ain't in you so hard
look DJ Quik as hard as hell he could
rap his ass off his beats are incredible
enough I feel like if I sat with him and
he heard from my shitty black man I [ __ ]
with his doings yeah most people to like
I just feel like
most people just kind of like who are
into your music they see it but after
like people people more people got to
give you a chance is that is the rap
check its obviously is it the smallest
check that you're getting right now you
know what it's it's I ain't gonna lie
it's damn near the smallest check but
it's a damn good check because other
business it's not fair to compare
cookies as animals is out of here so he
says we're not living in Florida at the
mall Italian cookies is an animal and
then you know him - oh is an animal -
and that's just you know - oh yeah for
sure
and everything else that I do is an
animal but the rat money is cool and
that's another thing going back to the
independent hype let them iTunes checks
on the first a month is a beautiful
thanks out to Empire distribution chart
- Charlie yeah you know it's it's nice
actually real nice that you can live off
it the thing is everybody want to call
themselves a boss everybody wants to be
an entrepreneur but like what are the
things that that what does it really
take to do that you know what's like a
day to day what do you have to handle
how much is on your plate burner man
enough to make me go crazy look you have
to learn how to hold your pee you got to
be a professional pee holders as you
know you never know that's important you
got to be just moving you got to be able
to starve yourself I sleep for hours a
night I invest all my own money into
myself so that way everything I'm
working I'm super passionate on but I'm
not gonna lose no money bro especially
my own money so it takes a lot from your
mind you know angle I am damn near
lightweight crazy from from running all
these businesses but at the end of the
day my kids going to be straight and I'm
a retired young so I'm not tripping like
at the end of the day that's the whole
goal is retired like in the 40s you know
people are dying these days man I need
some chill time 32 take a lot of money
to kick off a business night it takes it
takes mouthpiece to kick off the
business you poker it's all about it
does take some money but it's more about
how passionate you are about the more
hands-on you are with it the more you
can get it cracking because I don't
cracked off I mean cookie started with
19,000 we're probably going to you know
it's probably probably close to 10
million is here and from closing and
I've never learned nothing about
clothing I've never went to school for
it I don't got no high school education
I don't know anything about anything
except knowing that I was passionate
about doing it so you know you turn 19
G's into ten million in a year know you
that's what it took that kid mouthful
and shout out to you and Spencer for
keeping me laced because I probably buy
check it looks mighty fine 50% of the
clothing I wear
if you care you could add me to that
melon list and I'll support you
definitely in the Mafia boxless right
you know the vibe was right when I
walked in so you gonna get blessing the
work and we're putting all that instance
I say that to say this so I'm putting a
lot of that money that we're making back
in the cookie so like this cookie kazumi
yeah and so I thought I do but like the
jacket you're wearing man we're making
the money off that the margins on is
small because it's quality the dough
very like a lot of streetwear companies
do printables that's where your margins
are so we putting it back into it you
know we play with it in flipping around
a lot of dope collabs artists where the
hell are you man yg or Gucci yg ham
[ __ ] that [ __ ] was fire the Dipset [ __ ]
was fire finna do some mercy murder free
see murder and damn you know just bunch
of cool stuff just random stuff street
should talk about the like you said you
were kicking off a new series with be
real because prohibition you guys did
three of them three up he's my favorite
artists to work with man use is so easy
to work with and we get classic timeless
music together so we're trying to think
of a new name for a series I'm damming a
ton we didn't start a quote man yo-yo
should be you him and y'all should get
like spitter or dizzy right or somebody
do like a super see we were with the dog
we was a source where was a dog I saw
that it was like that me crazy and try
to reach out and kind of put it in the
ear shout to the dog that's my big
brother I was like look man you be real
me and Wiz or some super group that
means I mean even if it's five six song
type situation man have got to be on a
is it you were tour with Snoop its
legendary onstage that one time snoop
out smoke wiz with coffers yeah
everybody that video yeah can you can
you smoke a be can you hang with new can
you out do you think you get out smoke
out smoke snoop you know I don't know I
mean we blaze big together you know just
in Cosmo quiz I don't know I mean see
the thing is Wiz likes a certain kind of
weed iced mochas look you got one two
three four five seven eight nine you got
nine flavors of smoke from so each one
of these gives you different right so
I'm not sacked out smoke with because
with smokes like a chimney you know and
II just mouse out to jump now holiday I
relate to you know
but I don't know I mean we smoke
differently but was probably a little
more crazier than I am you know he's
tried he's an extremist he'll probably
just make sure that he smokes you in the
table and then be miserable
just have a [ __ ] agenda / on everybody
you know after he does that but I don't
know I think we're all equal
you know hunter be real smokes like me
real smokes big - what's the new
business I know you got the battle app
battle app is crazy which is funny
because like people battle doing
different [ __ ] like digit spinner
battles that we got I don't even know
how that happened we just have to do
that I got arrested in Miami the real
Joker or Miami joke or whatever do with
the tattoos on his face why are you most
[ __ ] not he's like a baby stitches or
he's a wannabe cinches or maybe he's
like extended version stitches but you
know there's just weird talent on battle
app but it's the best like it's cool
it's actually really really cool did he
get arrested for something he did on the
battlin no no he was out waving guns in
public or they say or sometimes like saw
that I saw him like the Joker yeah yeah
the joke it started I look he was he he
was on battle after last month and he
has wearing a diaper hiding in the cage
with a shotgun like he's crazy like that
guy but that's what battle-ax brings as
it brings like crazy people in the world
out that he'd look like against dude it
was kind of crazy you are like um you
know a boss like like I think like he
was talking about the entrepreneurial
thing earlier what would you like some
advice you would give to somebody who
wants to start up a business even if
it's not in the weed game just in
general man like an entrepreneur sure I
got two little I'm gonna write a book
one day when we go time but at the end a
the first number one rule is invest in
yourself invest your own money because
when you invest your own money you're
going to be a lot more a lot more like
attentive to what's going on the second
thing I would say is be passionate about
what you're going to invest in because
if you're not passionate about it and
you just try to do some little quick
thing like come on it took a minute to
get cookies where it's at so invest your
money be passionate and I say number
three is be hands-on because if you're
not hands-on with your own your own
brand or your business man people are
stealing it's going to fall apart don't
fall through the cracks yeah every
design cookies comes out I approve every
design I design and come up with half
the themes for it you know with the with
the album's I pick my own music I sit
there through all the mixing and
mastering you know the water I'm at the
fills at 4:30 in the morning make sure
there's no weird plastic taste because
it's a hot feel like you got to really
be bout your business if you want to be
about your business I'm talking about
you know your artwork on your albums
they're always that consistently flies
[ __ ] like even before like you were like
really really pop and I feel like
always hell with that's you know that's
another thing is like packaging and
branding is key like report you know
that's what kind of separated me in the
beginning when I was coming up with
people's like man prayer he might not be
doper but looked I'm covers dope all the
beats are dope the quality of the music
is dope it's consistent it doesn't stop
so packaging and branding what about for
a upcoming artist because I always like
see artists like hit don't hit me on
facebook like hey man should I pay to
open up for an artist bigger than me cuz
you know that's a thing you know what
here's here's a head I've heard that
you've done that before so here's the
story from the oh right how y'all like
this like sometimes you got do to got to
do right but I used to pay to get on and
this one promoter would treat me hella
funny I show up like 10 strippers and he
would charge me to bring him on stage to
dance he can't get a show for me right
now fifteen twenty thousand twenty two
whatever you ain't happening bro can't
do it get your money up and that's the
girl full circle it's like cool I paid
you back in the days to get on stage and
you treated me like the bum of the world
but now I'm not even to take your money
I don't need it it's the best feeling
ever it's like it's almost damn near
kind of like I'm damn you're getting
hired ticking about two on him no on
taking his money to do that what do you
mean no no I'm like number but you do
think it's already moves you know
sometimes invested pay to open up yeah
for sure I mean at the end of the day
look this world moves fast does Helen
[ __ ] going on you got to get hurt
somehow get on battle at - that's a good
wait on that battle Idol app is a great
way to be to be found for sure like we
see people's profiles explode within a
week they'll get more followers on
battle app and more interaction than on
the Instagram you've had for years but
invest in yourself man if you got to pay
to get on the show make sure it's the
right so make sure your dope make sure
what you're doing is like what you want
people to hear but don't do it all the
time
do it until until you have to and that's
about it going to lick within the
pipeline no man obviously we know about
the music you got your businesses that
you're going to be launching - man Reese
- charge child proof we charge dope as
hell you could drop the class star not
break it you know the weed business is
huge for me right now I mean cookies we
got exotics but the whole lemon Billy
Mathews vacuum sealer - that is a lot of
people's lives we made that to New York
yeah you know the water that I'm into
you know I'm really focused on the movie
packs right now we're riding over to you
know some Union riders that have a
pretty good movies in the pipeline
yeah the movies dope I'm not trying to
myself it's a story by me to marijuana
crime films are you going to be in the
movie or you got to explain you I'm not
gonna be in is mostly based it's based
on true events it's about the rise of
designer weed and trafficking so like
when I started hitting New York in
Atlanta in Florida and Arizona and you
know Indiana it's about no one's ever
focused on the rise of designer we like
this weed right that we're looking at
right here just when it got around the
world like if you were in Virginia and
you've seen as your mind was blown you
smokin Mexican dirt weeds right and so
that whole thing was kind of like the
blow era so we no one's covered it and
they probably won't cover all right so
that's what we're doing this could be a
biggie so I want to feel like I want to
act in it as a Denver low key pressure
you also know that you're gonna have to
take acting classes Ginola and I'm not
like an opera laughter I want me to be
buffing like you know kinda exaggerating
I'm not ready to hit the gym la yeah
yeah not yet yeah I'm on that dadbod
gang to band areas that bodies in broke
very super late yo how I know that your
your daughter's the most important thing
in your life you you know always a
posted around my mentor when you're not
around her yeah how do you um
you know when you because you're gone a
lot obviously working what's the easiest
way besides they always a FaceTime is it
you know they just say stay tapped in
with a little one it's just real
conversations like you know I mean
obviously FaceTime plays a big role and
talking on the phone but I mean there's
times where I get home from I don't know
how long it being on the road and I'll
Drive you know two hours to just go pick
her up from school have some lunch order
talk with her get her back home she's we
go a nice trip she spends time with me
she's actually moving close to me she's
been living a couple hours away five
years but she's actually moving in one
block away from me and that's going to
be the tightest experience in the world
it took a lot of you know baby mama you
know how it is but we were good friends
and we worked aside co-parenting yeah
coal parity is key and you know you know
it's a big deal so it's tight you know
I'm gonna have my kid there would mean
that's why my kind of that's why I said
I want to retire young because at the
end day when she gets into the teenage
years you know how it is you're the hero
she's beautiful I know right there
second mother when she gets into those
years was one thing you definitely want
to you know put her on game about I mean
just a ten a day yeah oh man I've been
teaching her since day one like you know
you can't trust any guy you know and if
they don't treat you the way I treat you
they're not the
one to dinner respect you and genuinely
enjoy your company and your laugh and
your smiled and they're not for you and
that's it yes there is have you having
your daughter get bigger have you like
hesita justed the way you treat females
hell yeah I'm not a dirtbag no more I
may be used to beat you got a video on
world so I believe was a chick hit and a
joint out of her vagina yes I'm a girl
i'ma keep it real like don't get it
messed up you know girls love big dudes
I've been having cracking since I was
like early in demand oh they don't had
it cracking I'm talking about lineups
girls I know you listen la you know what
it is well ha la squad I'm sorry ladies
I'm middle highways you know I miss
y'all and I'm sure you miss me too but
at the end of day
the dollar is definitely coming down be
a good man you can't trust these damn
girls now you can't you be on baller
alert hell that have you ever been
through any of that kind of drama I'm
always paranoid I always take a girl's
kind of set me up so I probably created
more drama than there was when the end
of the day it's like you got to be where
these girls get you caught up in some
you know hazy things you know they might
be married that might have ex pimp or
ex-boyfriend that might want to know
what you got going on so up I always
been on more on the paranoid type but
now I never had no problem skills I only
had girls tell me there and level one to
kill themselves or mean that's crazy I'm
just like she's a teddy bear teddy bear
fig I like Werner obviously you got tons
of music out packed with the last album
that you dropped right yeah yeah packs
went crazy I was crazy man I've
recognized it's getting a lot of play on
XM shout out the quavo on the dr. paul
paul wall you know sand and shout to
cosmo and elevators you know Ike refers
to the point where like you got to pay
for a quail feature it is Cueva like
know like yo man I'm gonna do this
feature and I'm whatever I'm in the band
but get smoke out of my mind yeah I'ma
be honest you know I don't really pay
for any feature everybody think white
oak label made me pay them about he did
I said all right little homie here's
your checking I'm saying do what you got
to do but you know that [ __ ] fire
though the hook is firing he's getting
in our respected mic I said sometimes
going back to the shows sometimes you
got to pay all the group problems I do
is out of pure vibes out of respect out
of people into work together quavo
that's the homie we've been worked
together on the record before and it was
love then but even got a little bigger
now so he needed his issue and it was it
was a fair deal but I'm not going to be
when the guys in front I definitely took
care of them and I feel like it
performed way more than I expected south
to quavo man I got this bag for you when
you get back in town too because this is
combustion learners open so let's do it
man and it's the new record oh if you
guys don't know burner got like
literally like you said how many how
many albums either 26 or 27 hey crazy
working go hit that Spotify and just
catch up yeah just go get hit that
Pandora even go to youtube if you aim
whatever it is just however you want to
hear hear
let's get this record on man it's
featuring Cueva paul walls called nice
new project styles p on the way in june
right job yeah call this call vibes
vibes
mmm weird weird album endeavour without
man December's call from seed to sale
and me and dolphin named objects is too
goddamn hard up here man he's like the
most serious dude ever up here yeah he's
the best poem he's cool we got it we got
a good vibe going on our album guy can't
wait to hear because y'all have worked
together in the past it's always
whistling we really both come from that
so that's just going to be tight this
lit man yo you already know what it is
always home for if I were laddie 230
burger